okay so I've been reading through
Fullmetal Alchemist on my YouTube
channel lately and one thing I have
spent way too much time researching and
finding out has been well what the hell
gender Envy is so the long story short
of it is that Envy is actually gender
neutral I got sent down this rabbit hole
in the first place because while he is
sometimes referred to as it in the manga
other characters sometimes refer to Envy
as he so which one is it well in
Japanese Envy is referred to with the
Kono or Watashi pronouns which are both
gender neutral pronouns so why then do
some characters call Envy he in the
English manga I think the main problem
here was that when Full Metal Alchemist
was being translated back in the early
2000s using they them as the go-to
pronouns for non-binary folks was not as
common as it is today so there you have
it language is confusing and English
kinda sucks with pronouns uh yeah I'm
sure they would agree